[overlapping arguing]
- NO, BUT I DON'T CARE.
- AND I'M TRYING TO HELP
PEOPLE OUT OVER HERE.
- NO, OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT,
JAQUELINE?
- NO, I DON'T KNOW. WHAT?
- YOU NEED TO THINK ABOUT
YOURSELF SOMETIMES,
BEFORE YOU START
INSINUATING YOURSELF
IN OTHER PEOPLE'S BUSINESS.
- WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT,
DEENYCE?
I'M GONNA INSINUATE MYSELF
WHENEVER AND WHEREVER
I PLEASE,
'CAUSE IT'S
A FREE COUNTRY, BITCH.
all: OOH.
- UH-UH.
- UH-HUH.
- UH-UH. OKAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
- OH, WE DOIN' THIS?
- YEAH, WE DOING THIS.
- OKAY, SO WE GONNA--HERE, BABY.
- YEAH, WE ARE ABOUT
TO FIGHT NOW.
- BRING IT ON THEN, BITCH.
LET'S GO.
- I AIN'T EVEN PLAYIN'.
'CAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT?
STEP TO ME THEN, GO AHEAD.
- I WISH YOU WOULD...
- STEP TO ME.
- STEP UP...
- NO, I WOULD LOVE FOR YOU
TO STEP TO ME,
I REALLY WOULD.
- TO ME RIGHT NOW, BITCH.
BUT YOU'RE JUST TALKIN',
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
- I DON'T EVEN CARE NO MORE.
- AND YOU'RE TALKING THOUGH,
AND THAT'S ALL YOU'RE DOING.
- CALL ME A BITCH AGAIN.
- OH, YEAH?
- OKAY.
- NO, SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
- YOUR WISH IS GRANTED.
- SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
- OH, YOU DO?
- OH, ABSOLUTELY.
SO WHY DON'T YOU COME
AND BRING IT THEN, BITCH?
all: OOH.
- SEE, NO.
YOU ARE RIDING
MY LAST NERVE.
AND I AIN'T EVEN PLAYIN'
NO MORE.
I AM NOT EVEN PLAYIN'
- OH, IT'S ON?
THEN LET'S DO SOMETHING,
OKAY?
YOU WANNA GO?
all: OOH.
- UH-UH.
- HUH?
THERE WE GO.
LET'S DO SOMETHING.
- UH-UH.
- UH-HUH.
- IT'S UH-HUH.
IT'S UH-HUH.
- UH-UH.
- LET'S DO SOMETHING, BITCH.
- WHAT?
[all gasping]
all: OOH.
both: WE TOLD YOU
NOT TO MESS WITH US, BITCH!
- Y'ALL JUST SAW THAT BITCH
TURN INTO TWO LITTLE GIRLS,
RIGHT?